once again it's very difficult to look
at the papers
to watch tv to consume any news really
without seeing all sorts of quite scary
stories about
the rise or the resurgence rather a
covert 19.
so i wanted just to look through some of
the the data some of the numbers to get
a sense of
whether things have changed since we
last spoke whether it is time to get
worried
about this disease uh and about the way
that it's rising not just in the uk but
around europe and i've got lots of
charts i'm afraid
i want to show you but bear with me
because actually there's some
interesting unexpected stuff in there
and i'm going to start with some good
news in the middle i've got some
slightly less good news
and then we'll finished with some
relatively good news some slightly
reassuring
stuff so starting with that first bit of
good news uh and this is
i think news we should all be
celebrating um this shows you the number
of deaths from covert 19
in england well similar story as well i
should say in scotland
and northern ireland as well and just
look at how
far they've come down they are
incredibly low
at the moment the lowest that they've
been really since the start of the
pandemic number of people dying
of this disease and this is probably of
all the measures about the best
measure specifically looking at covert
19 from the office of national
statistics
and you can see it's come down from a
kind of daily rate of over a thousand
people dying a day back at the height of
the pandemic
it was down at around 40 people dying a
day
uh in the middle of july and look at
where we are now it's around 12 deaths a
day
uh right now uh as i say it's about as
low as it
as it has been thus far may well be the
lowest it it
it ever is because we may well see them
start to rise as we'll come to
in a second but nonetheless it's worth
just taking in that shot and
there's another way of looking at this
which is looking at total deaths across
england and wales
uh this is all death so so from all
causes and you can see pretty clearly
the impact of the pandemic there that's
around the kind of march april
uh may period uh there there's a few
dinks here where
there are bank holders it's worth just
saying the latest data affected by that
august bank holiday but nonetheless you
get the picture a big increase
in deaths there but it's come down very
sharply ever since actually right now
there's covered as a part of it so this
is the higher this is the more people
are dying of covert 19.
and you can see that's pretty much the
equivalent of that chart i just showed
you a second ago coming down down down
down
so that now actually and for the recent
uh
few months uh fewer people have been
dying of covert 19 then have been dying
of influenza
and pneumonia put together so it just
gives you a sense
that those are pretty comparable
diseases and actually a lot fewer people
dying of covid
right now than than flu and pneumonia
um but i want to get to something that
does concern me within these data and
they've just been released
by the ons and it's the most definitive
sense of kind of where we are
one thing that has concerned me you know
for quite some time
you've had a lot of focus on protecting
the nhs there's a lot of focus more
recently on
care homes obviously we saw an
incredible um terrifying increase in
deaths in care homes
but we've talked a little bit less about
what's happening
on the domestic front so people dying at
home and this
i find quite concerning so this chart is
basically just showing you the number of
people dying above
the seasonal average in various
different settings so this is a number
of people dying in hospital and this is
the weeks since the beginning of the
pandemic so
around that's around the kind of march
april period an increase there of people
dying
in hospital but you know all of the
emphasis was about protecting
the nhs and that was done pretty
successfully actually right now fewer
people dying in hospitals actually have
done since
for some time fewer people dying in
hospitals than
than would normally do around this time
of year care homes well you can see
compared with the five-year average a
massive increase in the number of people
dying
in care homes you know this in a way was
the great scandal
uh of this pandemic they weren't
protected there was a very big increase
in deaths in care homes
but now look it's come down so it's
below the five-year average fewer people
dying in care homes that would normally
be
dying around this time of year but have
a look at this this line here shows you
the number of people dying at home
compared with how
many people would normally die of all
causes and
it went up about the same level as
hospitals but just look at what's
happened since
fewer people dying in care homes fewer
people dying in hospitals
but the number of people dying above the
average above the average at home
is significantly higher than it would
normally be
and that just hasn't changed you can see
a bit of a dink there but that's mainly
i think a bank holiday
effect what does it mean we don't really
know and this is the frustrating thing
people haven't really looked into this
as much as they should have done it is a
potentially a national scandal so many
people
dying at home is it because they're not
going into hospital quite possibly that
they're not going into a hospital
where they might otherwise have died so
deaths are kind of transferred from
hospital to elsewhere or are these
deaths that wouldn't have happened
otherwise and indeed they're happening
because people are too nervous about
going into hospitals
i think we need to know more about that
and all we have so far are these kind of
statistics and i feel
people don't talk about that all that
much anyway though like i say most of
the news on deaths at the moment
is actually very much good news by the
way i should say the cumulative total
we're talking about twenty five point
four
thousand twenty five and a half thousand
people dying at home it's actually
about the same as who died uh in care
homes above the average so you're
talking about more
more excess deaths probably within a
week or two at home in domestic settings
than we had in care homes and yet
we don't really talk about that anyway
like i say most of this news
about deaths about covert 19 and how
many people are dying
is thankfully good news and you know we
are down at this kind of very low level
at the moment but as i said it may well
be that that's the lowest it gets that
we start to see an
increase in deaths uh in the coming
months is that something to be afraid of
well clearly it's not good
news um but it is slightly prefigured by
what we're seeing on the continent which
is a rise in covert 19 cases and you can
kind of
get a sense of that by looking at covert
19 cases per 100 000
in a variety of different countries so
this is france you can see the initial
pandemic
and you see right now cases per 100 000
are higher so population adjusted are
higher now than they were in the
pandemic it looks kind of scary doesn't
it similar thing for spain look
cases per hundred thousand even higher
there during the pandemic but even
higher now
than they were back in april uh and then
in the uk it's starting to come up
as well so there's you've probably seen
some of the pictures
uh some of the charts elsewhere looking
at that increase in cases in the uk well
it is coming up it's nowhere near
quite as high as it was as in france and
in spain but
i've said this before but it's worth
just repeating
when you see charts like this i'd be
super cautious about getting terrified
of them yes it does look like spain
is having far more cases than it did
back at the time of the pandemic
but that's primarily because we weren't
doing that much testing around there
and a better way of measuring how much
covert 19 is going around it's not
flawless but a slightly better way
is looking at the positivity rate so how
many of those tests are coming back
positive and if we show you that similar
kind of lines similar kind of thing but
now we're looking at the percentage of
positive tests just look at the shape of
these charts and how different they are
so france
actually weren't measuring this very
well back then so you know you can't
read all that much from that
but look at spain so back at the time of
the peak of the the pandemic so around
april may at least kind of
you know more than a quarter of those
tests were coming back positive
in spain now you're talking about it's
just over 10
now that you know it's a high level it's
of course we're concerned for
for many epidemiologists but nonetheless
we're not talking like anything like the
prevalence of the disease that we saw
back
uh in april uh or indeed march so you
know
those those charts that you've seen
before same same thing for the uk by the
way you know back in the uk
one in three tests coming back positive
back at the peak now
it's just over one percent again no
cause for complacency
but it is worth comparing what happened
there with what happened now
that was a terrible incident um this is
quite a different thing
and so you know all of the the concern i
think a lot of people are showing that
there's this second wave that's similar
indeed
potentially worse than the first well we
haven't yet seen it in the data nothing
like it
but does that necessarily mean that the
uk is going to avoid it you can see at
these lines here
this uk the uk the white line looks like
it's not quite in the same league as
what's happening in
france and spain well don't be deceived
by that because what we know from last
time around
is and you might remember this we were
looking at all those charts showing the
different trajectories of different
countries like beer italy and beat spain
and you could see that the uk was
following on those paths
so that at the start it might have
looked unlikely that we were going to
have
10 000 deaths but actually if you had
looked at the data you would have seen
that we were basically following where
italy was and we were going to have 10
000 deaths within a week or so back at
the time you know a lot of people
didn't like to hear that but we were
reporting it well this time around how
does it look let's just compare
those trajectories you can see spain
there this is the number of cases and
it's just a seven day average
of new cases and you can see it's rising
uh
relatively kind of steadily there and
that's that's where the
14th of september so we're kind of
starting at the point where they passed
2000 cases in the latest wave
of the disease uh and then you can see
france
so in on the 14th of september they were
kind of along that line but not quite as
far up to about 8 000
a day whereas spain was kind of around
the 10 000 a day
on average and there's the uk so you can
see we're kind of about
three weeks or so behind france and
spain
and what does that imply it implies that
within
three weeks or so the number of cases
here is likely to be up from around two
three thousand to around ten thousand
i mean it does it that is what this data
is suggesting
uh you don't know the future for sure
but this is what this implies
is that the disease is spreading in this
country and it's getting up to those
kind of levels so
that is an important thing and it does
imply uh i'm afraid that more people
will have to go to hospital and more
people will die
of this disease because the disease is
still a very serious disease
but the big question is this you know
are we going to see the kind of deaths
and the kind of spread that we saw last
time around and here's where the news
gets a little bit more reassuring
and where i want to underline that we
really shouldn't be panicking
this shows you the increase in death
that we've seen so far
in france it's not very sharp indeed
same in spain it's going up but it's
still
relatively shallow and what i want to do
is to compare that so those trajectories
these start in kind of like um
late august these trajectories i want to
compare them with what we saw
in the first wave of the pandemic uh one
two three four five deaths
after they went beyond uh a certain
level but
10 deaths and here is what happened in
the first wave you can see it's a
totally different story
it's a totally different story death's
rising
exponentially and incredibly fast in
that first wave
whereas at the moment we've yet to see
anything that you would call exponential
when it comes
to death so that is relatively
reassuring
and when you have a look at the kind of
difference between
cases and deaths and this is something
that i think is worth doing
something pops out something immediately
pops out which is that
what i've done here is i've plotted uh
deaths which is this black line versus
the positivity rate so that measure of
how much disease there is
in the country uh this is for spain and
what you can see is look
the amount of covert in the country this
white line has gone up recently
but unlike last time around where it was
moving in lockstep with the number of
people who were dying
the number of deaths has gone up far
more gradually so you're not seeing as
many
people dying per case of this disease
as last time around and as i've said
before
we're just going to have to wait and see
whether that is something that lasts or
whether that is just
an aberration but that's really
important and the same thing in the uk
we've yet to see positivity go up that
much but so far deaths remain
relatively low we will keep an eye on
that but it suggests this isn't
manifesting in quite the same way in the
kind of epidemiol
epidemiological sense but we will
probably see as i say cases going up and
hospitalizations we've already seen
start to go up i saw a chart like this
just the other day again it's worth just
remembering that
while there is certainly an increase
here and you've maybe seen charts that
just
focus on this more recent increase while
there is an increase
it's worth just remembering it's nowhere
near the kind of increases we saw early
on
early on in this pandemic there were
exponential incredibly steep increases
in hospitalization
so far we don't see that exponentiality
as i say we will keep an eye on that but
so far
the news is tentatively reassuring
um and the similar thing elsewhere as
well even in spain where
hospitalizations are going up relatively
sharply
it's still nothing like the kind of
sharpness we saw before
so far so we'll keep an eye on these
data
but as i say the lesson from last time
around is that
by watching what's happening in france
spain the uk can get an
early glimpse of where we may be heading
and here's
where a little bit of good news i think
is worth just bearing in mind in spain
it may look like those case trajectories
are going up and up and up and indeed
they are
but actually the growth rate is starting
to tail off
in spain at the moment we'll have to see
if that continues in the coming
uh weeks and days but that growth rate
so far is starting to tail off
to the extent that you remember this um
idea of the reproduction rate r
and you remember how one is the
important level that you need to be at
well in spain
they think on the basis of their kind of
formal measures of
of our that they're now below one in
fact actually they're down below around
0.5 on the the reproduction rate
that's crucially important because it
suggests at least on the basis of their
numbers
that the disease is coming under control
so they've seen a surge in cases
and now it's starting to come under
control if that is the case
that is potentially very encouraging for
the uk given we seem to be following in
their footsteps and indeed
many of the policies that we've
introduced in this country you know the
rule of six they've got kind of rule of
ten
uh in spain similar kind of policies um
so
if it is the case we are following off
to spain and it is the case that their
disease
excuse me is starting to come under
control then that's encouraging
and that might be a bit of good news but
we need to just keep an eye on these
data
over the course of the next few weeks